nene leakes and Kim Zolciak are going at
it again I absolutely love it
you know how drama feels the Real
Housewives of Atlanta co-stars got into
a new fight on Instagram on Thursday
after nene leakes Reshard a video that
Kim's daughter Brielle posted to
snapchat months ago from a party at
Nene's house that's a 20 year olds
crouched down on Nene's bathroom as
roaches are seen on the floor
Nene clapped back sharing this pic to
Instagram writing that she was going to
live in her quote roach-infested
brand-new home along with the hashtags
jealous prejudices and potty mouth
trashy children know in another post the
49 year old reality star called Brielle
quote racist as well as slammed Kim for
being a quote trashy mom hot while
Brielle has yet to respond really Kim
took to Instagram to defend her daughter
explaining that the first clip was one
Brielle posted not realizing there was a
giant bug in front of her until fans
responded to let her know and she
immediately removed the video Kim added
that the second video was sent privately
from Brielle to her mom while they were
at Nene's home filming for the hit Bravo
show and that no one would have seen it
had Nene not posted the video herself in
a separate post Kim said quote at this
point I almost feel sad for you at nene
leakes
I will continue to pray for you Nene
then responded telling her side of the
story I'm a tough girl calling Kim trash
and a quote huge liar they're housewives
co-star Kenya Moore also chimed in
sharing Nene's original post adding
quote I totally agree with you about
that devil Kenya Real Housewives of
Atlanta is still filming season 10 and
we can't wait to see how this plays out
on screen
[Music]
you